Hello,
you're listening to under the skin where
I Russell brand ask what's beneath the
surface of people we admire of the ideas
that define our time.
The history we're told.
This show is sponsored by me and my
rebirth tour.
I sponsored it.
You see the next couple of shows are
sold out,
but there's still some tickets available
for grimsby.
10th of July,
Richmond,
17th of July,
Cambridge,
18th of July in 25th of July.
Go Russell brand.com
for tickets.
Now it's time for under the skin.
The nine
is in all of our social activist and
filmmaker known for political analysis
and criticism of corporate
globalization.
Her books include no logo,
the shock doctrine,
and this changes everything which was a
New York Times best seller.
She frequently appears on global and
national list of top influential
thinkers.
One occasion higher up than me,
which was infuriating and in 2016 was a
ward and probably all occasions.
That's the only time I've been on the
list and in 2016 was awarded the Sydney
Peace Prize for activism on climate
justice.
Her new book,
which will be talking about in some
depth is no,
is not enough at MCO.
Here is this is a look at how we arrived
at this surreal political moment,
how to keep it from getting a lot worse
and how if we keep our heads,
we can flip the script.
So primarily in this book,
no is not enough.
You're talking about trump and what
trump epitomizes and what trump is
perhaps a symptom of something that you
can pray.
See in this new audio form I can try.
Um,
first of all,
it's great to be with you and I should
have done some of that.
You could.
What I'd really love you.
I think you're really beautiful person.
I think you're a body Sattva to use a
Buddhist term,
a person that's helping other people to
enlightenment perhaps at the expense of
our own.
What do we want to hear?
That's actually,
I think the price.
Like I say that there's people that
could go over if they want it,
but they,
I know I'll stick around here for a
while trying to help other people over.
So that's quite a good compliment.
I remember with great affection the
previous times that we've met the first
time when I was in an erratic and
metropolitan whirlwind of romance with
my future wife and having just in fact
interviewed Donald Trump,
primarily motivated then by this curious
impulse that I had of like,
how is this guy so rich when,
to me,
he seems like he's an idiot.
That's why I couldn't understand it.
Of course I understood that someone had
given him his money,
follow the lead,
but then,
but meeting him,
I kept probing him and thinking,
what is it?
How have you got this money?
What's going on?
And that was before he was president.
We didn't know that he was merely a man
in the ascent at that point.
So it seems as good a point as any to
launch into your book having
complimented you and my gratitude for
you coming here and being on our podcast
and the niceties that be observed.
So thank you.
Um,
so look,
I,
I wanted to just put trump in some kind
of context.
This is not looking at the psychology.
Um,
you know,
there's,
I think a lot out there just about sort
of pathologizing him as this extreme,
extreme individually and he's certainly
an extreme individual,
but he's also just a symptom of the
culture in so many ways.
He is the fulfillment of so many of the
most dangerous trends.
I'm just the worst,
the worst of us really.
And there's this way in which he's so
bizarre.
And so unlike what we're used to from
politicians that I think we talk about
him as if he's some sort of Martian,
you know,
what did he do now?
Could he really have just tweeted that?
I mean,
what a like this is this,
everyone's,
it describes the state they're in as,
as shock,
but I see it as really,
it's more like a cliche.
It's a cliched outcome.
Like of course a culture that fetishized
as well,
that federal Spanish eyes celebrity that
fetishize is fakeness.
It at every level.
You know,
if you wrote a science fiction novel
about a world in which the United States
elected Donald Trump as their president
and you handed it to your editor editor
would tell you that.
It was too cliched and outcome,
right?
It's too predictable and outcome,
and so I think trump is the fulfillment.
I think you're right,
was thinking about the theatrical term
grotesque,
grotesque is merely an exaggeration of
the ordinary to make it more
identifiable and recognizable and these
sort of traits were always present under
the Bush presidency.
Galumphing individualism was president
and buccaneer international,
like internationalist attitude don't
know internationally.
Those interventions about.
So yeah,
the way it's entirely predictable.
One of the things that are like a
fingerprint or I suppose it's because I
have the privilege of a comedic
perspective.
He's sort of something about him that's
likable comparatively.
You know what I feel that it is,
is that people got odd on sort of
Clintonian Blair,
right?
You know,
at least he's new labor and like this
kind of charming,
slick,
superficial,
technocratic,
bureaucratic,
so vinea of pleasantness,
but Marston indifference and ignorance
to the needs of the majority of people.
That was disingenuous and untruthful and
Donald trump may be many things and
clearly as your book outlined,
he is those things.
But what you also seems to be is
authentic in a bizarre way.
He's not logging.
There's something mad about someone's
lying,
but he,
he's telling you the truth about being a
liar.
It,
you know,
so he gets caught lying all the time,
but he's open about the fact that he's a
liar and he's corrupt and he does
whatever it takes to win.
And so you can't catch them out on
anything.
And I think that's what people mean when
they were like,
well,
at least he's honest.
Like they don't mean he's technically
honest.
They understand that he lies all the
time,
tick authentically inauthentic or
something like that.
Um,
but do you think I'm talking to in a
sense,
no,
me about economy and energy,
but even though,
I mean to get too hippy dippy here,
but like when you,
like if you're watching Hillary Clinton
talk on television,
there's people.
If people were in the lead up to that
election and then you watched Donald
Trump.
So there is a,
even in the grotesqueness and evidently
the content was irrelevant because if
someone gets some of the more outrageous
things,
so you know,
the sexiest things,
the racist things,
if those things are irrelevant,
then what?
Easier.
That's getting traction.
What easier that's reaching people.
Uh,
my idea is that it's authenticity.
There's like,
well fuck it,
you know,
sort of think,
oh wow,
this guy is not Hillary Clinton where
Hillary Clinton,
most people don't seem to know how to
talk like,
well you see them and like tim resume
talking off the Greenfield.
You think this person is almost not a
human.
They don't.
They don't know Jesus.
I don't know what we're going to do
that.
Whereas Donald Trump,
when he says,
yeah,
I was eating chocolate cake.
You something.
This is bizarre,
but there's something about it that's
not what I've been used to for the last
24 years.
And I can see how people are really
disenfranchised and disillusioned might
find it appealing.
Well,
I think there's also something,
you know,
Hillary Clinton,
Blair,
um,
you know,
these figures are,
they are the symbol of the Davos class,
like the people up on the mountain top
at those already.
Well,
it's the party that not,
I mean,
you were invited,
but most people were not invited to
write that.
It's,
it's the party of this,
this sort of the winners in this,
in this global economy have a small
group of super winters and,
and huge numbers of,
of locked out people at the bottom of
that mountain.
And so I think the data summit became
this sort of symbol,
and this is why this phrase devost class
came a little bit into currency,
right?
It's this world where you had the
politicians hobnobbing with the ceos,
the billionaires and then a list
celebrities blessing the whole thing.
And um,
and it was,
it was a world that most people had
absolutely no access to.
Right?
And I think there's something about
trump and the way there was a strange
kind of generosity to his wealth in that
he did invite the world in.
Like,
I mean,
most,
most wealthy people in the world right
now,
the super rich don't want to flaunt
their wealth.
Like they understand,
like Bill Gates doesn't want us to see
his,
his many mansions and he doesn't know
gun curing malaria.
He wants us to see his altruism,
right?
Whereas trump said to the world,
like,
come into my mansion,
right?
I'm going to turn it into a reality TV
show.
Like people were invited into his wealth
and there's a way in which I think
there,
there is a,
there was gratitude for that.
He,
he,
um,
and I think that that is something of
what people mean by authenticity.
Authenticity is such a strange word to
use to describe this sort of festival of
fakeness that is the trump family.
Yes.
Um,
but,
you know,
and I don't think it is a message that
could have sold if the alternative was
not Hillary Clinton.
I think if Bernie had been running
against trump,
the absurdity of this,
you know,
this family that shows in their first
televised interview to address Americans
on a series of golden thrones,
right?
Remember that interview that they did.
So he loves the goal.
He's like a
sofa.
Yeah,
like an emperor or assaulting.
Interestingly,
the imagery,
the golden in our country,
the image of him with Nigel farage and a
golden elevate something that became a
kind of an emblem,
but the but the brazenness seems like an
authenticity.
How devoid and bereft of hope must we
be?
How disillusioned and despairing must we
have been that people,
insignificant numbers of women and
people from demographics that you would
imagine it would feel particularly
offended are like,
no,
we prefer that.
We prefer that.
And I think there's a very,
very important lesson for the left in
that.
And I don't see the left learning.
Well,
it depends how you define the left,
right?
I think there is,
I think fairness and sharing kindness.
I think there has been a learning.
I mean,
I.
When I look at the Corbyn campaign here
and which I think in some ways is a
reaction to trumpism,
right?
I mean this,
this completely unfocused,
grouped unselect the Anti brand,
right?
Jeremy Corbyn is,
I mean the person who actually started
applying the principles of marketing to
political parties in a serious way was
Tony Blair.
I mean he.
Well,
I mean when I remember when I was
writing no logo 20 years ago,
it was shocking that there was this
politician who used the word branding to
describe a political party.
I mean the new labour,
new labour and,
and they,
they were rebranding the Labour party,
giving it a new name.
A new logo was like new coke.
Right.
And what I wrote no logo is that Tony
Blair's Labour party was like a labor
scented party.
And,
and this was shocking in the 19 nineties
that you would sort of apply the
techniques used to sell dishwashing
liquid liquid and Coca Cola to a
political party that he was divorcing
this word labor,
which traditionally meant working people
from,
from it was [inaudible] it and just
turning it into a brand,
pulling it up from its roots.
And what I found really moving about
about Corbin's campaign,
watching it,
you know,
online,
because I wasn't here and particularly
the Ken loach a little films right?
Was that he put workers for the workers,
started in his campaign,
just regular working people and indeed
public sector workers who have been so
steadily vilified over the past 40 years
were the stars of his campaign,
not him,
you know,
and then you'd hear be hearing from
nurses and pediatricians breaking down
crying and teachers just talking about
the real impacts of austerity and then
you just see the logo labor and it just
meant labor,
but it wasn't,
it just meant workers.
It just meant it meant what it
originally meant.
And so it sort of felt like,
well,
I think people are learning the lessons
of trump.
They might not be learning it in the US
yet,
but I think I feel like here there was a
reaction against this,
this fakery.
Whereas in the states you have liberals
who think that the solution to trump is
getting oprah to run against him.
I mean,
seriously or Mark Zuckerberg get get,
get a liberal billionare to run against
trump and all will be.
Well,
if the broader context like,
isn't it like,
um,
I wouldn't Yanis Varoufakis Yanis
Varoufakis coming in when he was,
he said like,
I think Wolfgang Schauble said the
democracies.
All right.
As long as you don't change anything.
Right.
When you started out saying about Blair
in the mentality of branding,
he was doing something.
Of course it was extremely small in
retrospect.
History is totally disgusting.
That was a lovely North American
reaction to some British coffee I'm
supposed to say.
I think it's lovely.
That's right.
But that's a reaction now I winching and
recalling in.
Hold on,
sorry.
I just had to do that bitter espresso.
I'm sorry.
It was just,
I felt I needed to super caffeinate
myself to your mouth with you.
Reach through your ears.
I shuttered.
It was a shoulder.
Can I shops a funny story about that?
So I,
I,
as you can tell,
I'm North American and,
but I,
I did live in this country for,
for one year,
um,
when I was 10 years old and had an
absolutely terrible time.
And,
and I,
I,
um,
went to,
uh,
we lived in Oxford and I went to a
school that I don't think exists anymore
called Bishop Kirk.
We had that burned down because of you.
But see what North American kids do to
bond is like the easiest way that you
can make friends as a kid in North
America is to trash the food,
you know,
at the school cafeteria or,
or it's summer camera,
whatever it is.
That's,
that's how,
that's one of the ways you,
you bond.
And so my first,
yeah,
uh,
we,
we went to the cafeteria and they gave
us some terrible food and they,
I remember that,
that the pictures of custard,
which was a new phenomenon to me,
pewter pitchers of custard and I sat
down at the table of my new would be
friends at age at,
I think I was nine at this point,
not yet 10.
And I said,
this is disgusting.
A little girl named Katie Bennett,
who was the vicar's daughter,
looked up and said,
I think it's lovely.
That's when I realized I wouldn't have
no British friends even when you had
been raised by wolves.
Definitely,
yeah.
As you criticized our pitchers of
custard,
our listeners,
we're off to voting booths and ticking
the box.
Mark the UKIP.
They're lovely.
Lovely.
I can have a sip of this coffee again
and then say it.
Nicer reaction.
I think it's a lovely well done,
but that was a little bit of a swallow
that looked like you were disgusted.
Naomi Klein,
so you were there very much like the
little boy,
the emperor's new clothes you wear.
The little girl that pointed out that
the custard was actually disgusting.
Now I remember reading in,
I read no logo when it was the coolest
book to read at the time and I was a
heroin addict at that time,
so some of the more dense passages were
tricky and I was already in Cuba while
making,
as I'm sure I've told you,
a chewing gum commercial,
so it was felt somewhat conflicted.
I was in a really no logo which had been
reading before I left.
I was reading it.
I was making a chewing gum commercial,
the most vacuous of all products,
of course,
unnecessary mimicking of mastication
while the world staffs and I was in Cuba
where unlike a sort of where there was
the experiment of socialism was sort of
withering before the eyes,
but still something very beautiful and
incredible and you I suppose in that
book,
No logo,
bringing capitalism to Cuba personally.
I've personally doing my level best.
I was like an agent in a sense to try to
try to get naked.
Come on guys,
give it a go.
It's not that bad.
They in my fraternity in solidarity,
get that mural down.
Have you tried to delicious coke my
shop.
I'm like,
try this Bacardi.
You'll love it.
It is an insult.
Now tap.
I'm like,
it's like when you talk there about Tony
Blair coopting the language of branding
and consumerism going and applying it in
a political sphere.
Isn't it almost like that the political
sphere is an enclave within the uber
context of consumerism and capitalism,
so of course that language is going to
have a greater efficacy than a sort of a
particular topical political language
and ideology because we're not living in
a political culture.
We are living in a consumer culture,
so that language,
those images,
that kind,
that kind of discourse is going to be
more effective because we don't,
we all agree now the other than sort of
like,
uh,
like in the last election in this
country is cause for optimism in a sense
because you sort of think,
oh,
people who vote in our kind of kindness
and people have had enough and people
are sick of the old models,
but you know,
ultimately things are continuing in the
same way,
isn't it?
Because what we're really,
we live in a consumer culture as opposed
to a democratic culture.
I just wonder if it isn't cyclical like
Wah Wah,
whether we've just maxed out on.
I mean,
this is way I hope.
I hope that Donald Trump is as far as
we're going to take this extraordinary
experiment of,
of,
of selling absolutely everything in
life,
a corporatizing,
every bit of the comments,
every bit of public space and yes,
then applying the treating politics as
if it is a corporation and applying the
rules of marketing and branding to
politics is a natural extension of that.
But I think,
I think it's changing and I think there
is room for a,
another kind of another kind of
political project.
I always felt when I was writing no
logo,
that there was something inherently
hopeful in the fact that companies like
Nike and starbucks and apple were using
ideas like revolution,
community transcendence to sell consumer
products that could never deliver these
things.
Right.
Um,
and the fact that this started to happen
at the height of the neoliberal period
at the,
you know,
at,
at the,
at the fulfillment of the Reagan
Thatcher Project,
I mean this is when it up to the
eighties,
the model was,
you know,
you make a product a and as a
corporation you are in the business of
making products and selling those
products.
And you would then slap a logo on it to
differentiate it from other products in
the marketplace and buy advertisements
and tell people about it.
But what changed in the nineties is that
these companies,
and this is what no logo is about,
is what the meaning of this flip of,
of companies like Nike emerging and
saying,
well,
actually,
we're not a shoe company.
We're not a what,
you know,
we're not a trainer company.
We are about the idea of transcendence
through sports,
right?
We are about the idea of you being your
best of,
uh,
of,
of any kind of,
uh,
you know,
being your best.
Just do it.
That's what,
that's what it was about.
Starbucks announced that the meaning of
their brand was the third place,
not home,
not work,
but community,
a place where we gather,
right?
And this was the period where apple
started using the iconography of every
revolutionary movement and Gandhi,
Martin Luther King.
Um,
you know,
as an,
it just said,
think different,
right?
And these huge billboards.
So,
I mean,
on the one hand you can wring your hands
and say,
oh,
they're coopting all of our ideas.
Right?
But I always found it quite hopeful
because with all the best market
research,
what they were finding was that we
wanted more than just trainers and
laptops and,
and lattes and for capitalism,
this is a great recipe because it keeps
you shopping because as soon as you,
um,
you know,
as soon as you unwrap this new thing
that was supposed to bring you community
and revolution,
you're immediately dissatisfied and have
to shop some more.
So that's great for an economic system
built on growth.
But it does mean that that part of
ourselves that longs to be part of
something bigger than just our atomized
existence and shopping is parental
perennially unfulfilled.
So for,
for,
for me as a political animal,
I always thought,
well,
we should thank them.
They've done our market research for us.
Um,
and so it is the role of social
movements to rebuild a,
uh,
opportunities for people to actually get
real community,
right?
Because it's not a coincidence that
these companies started selling these
ideas.
At the very moment when every public
institution,
um,
every,
every place where we used to get that
sense of belonging,
whether it was organized religion,
you know,
whether it was the public square,
all of this is being eroded.
So now we're going,
we're,
we're getting it in a temporary state
through shopping.
Um,
but you know,
I think we are at a moment where we're
starting to see signs that we're
actually getting it from rebuilding our
sense of community and belonging.
No.
If the accompanying component,
all of the advent of capitalism,
some grotesque,
a Uber instantiation of which we are
currently uber the car that really now
the,
they have now the,
those synonyms have dovetailed.
So this sort of Uber version we labor
beneath the,
the,
uh,
the accompanying idea of socialism has
possibly be.
I think it'd been discredited because I
don't think you can,
like,
you know,
when you look at sort of perhaps British
socialism,
which is the famous people famously,
there's as much to methodism as marks
one recognizes that there's not the
soul.
There is not just one epistemology for
the idea of fairness and kindness.
There is not just one lineage,
not just one room,
but what I feel is that battle has been
won and I retro spective,
resurrection of those old ideas will not
be fulfilling,
but precisely the phenomena that you
speak of when you say,
oh,
there's this perennial yearning for
belonging now that can be co opted by.
Capitalism can be co opted by,
consumerism that you can attach the idea
of,
I want this new phone to the I am an
individual.
I am free.
You can.
What is the indigenous feeling and how
can the indigenous feeling be properly
utilized?
I don't think by mechanistic or
materialistic idea when we are dealing,
I think with metaphysics,
when we're dealing in fact with the
human spirit,
when we're dealing with something,
even when spoken of in secular terms,
that is a my view,
undeniably a spiritual idea,
but it's also a scientific idea.
I mean the reality of interconnection,
the reality that we are not atomized
individual,
that we are exist within webs of
connection with other human beings and
with the natural world.
We exist in relationships of dependence
and interdependence.
How do you mean by that?
Do you mean by that knowing that we
can't exist without clean water,
we can't exist without healthy soil.
We can't exist without an atmosphere
that creates a bubble that is safe for,
for,
for humanity,
and that it's a very fragile state.
Right?
So we can tell ourselves a narrative,
and we talked about this last time,
right?
I mean the narrative that we have been
telling ourselves since the dawn of the
scientific revolution,
which is a narrative of dominance and
apartness from nature that's in the,
in the span of human history began with
agriculture or industry.
Did you just say,
um,
I said scientific revolution,
but I mean,
I think it's an interplay between three
forces.
One is Judeo Christianity and,
and the scientific revolution and all
kinds of new,
uh,
ideas that put humans on a sort of ego
trip and imagining that all would be
known one day.
And then key technologies that actually
seemed to make the dream of domination
real and the key technology and all of
that was the steam engine where you can
tell yourself a story about who you're
going to dominate nature all you want.
But until the steam engine,
that's a fantasy because you can only
sell your ships when the wind blows.
You are in a relationship,
a dialogue with the natural world.
You need wind in order to sale.
You can tell yourself a story,
uh,
of dominance,
um,
about your,
your,
your factory.
But the fact is before the steam engine,
you needed rushing water.
You need a water,
a water wheel that,
that,
that needed the water at a certain
level,
right?
So there was a negotiation with the
natural world.
And I think the power of the steam
engine,
um,
was this idea that now you really are
God.
Human beings really are God in that you
can sell your ships whenever you want.
You are the boss of nature.
And this is the way the steam engine
would market it.
And so I think it was,
I think you had,
was it,
you'll now I'll pull to try and know
about kind of thing about power and
autonomy that you,
you are now the boss of the natural
world and also more of a boss of your
workers because when your factories are
immobile,
we mean you can build them wherever
because you have portable energy,
you're not,
you don't build it where,
where the,
where the water is and then you're kind
of captive to your workers.
You can,
uh,
you can be more abusive boss.
You can go where,
where there's a surplus of labor and you
know,
a lot of what I'm talking about comes
from some terrific research by a Swedish
historian named Andreas mom.
Um,
so I think,
I think it was a gradual process where
you had the ideas but the ideas weren't
real until you had the technology.
But now we're in this era where it turns
out we were never the boss.
I mean,
this is why I believe climate change is
a spiritual crisis and a narrative
crisis as well as an ecological crisis.
Because what the natural world is
telling us,
you know,
when asphalt
is melting and Cambridge in Arizona this
summer,
um,
and when Goldman Sachs is buffeted by
Super Storm Sandy is,
you will,
you are not the boss.
Every action has a reaction.
You are still in dialogue with the
natural world.
Timeframe is altered.
Exactly.
So it was not,
there was,
there was about 200 years where we could
tell ourselves this narrative of
apartness and separate NASPA.
But this is why I say it's,
it's not just,
it's not just a spiritual story.
And I think the reason why civilizations
understood this for so long is because
they were living at relationships of
interdependence with nature.
Yes.
And a lot of that folk mythology and a
sort of a early pre monotheistic
religion contained within it.
The ideas that we are rediscovering and
indeed rebranding as scientific
discoveries.
They were already there.
They were already present.
People talk of mindfulness now is like,
oh,
it turns out that mindfulness does
really help high heart disease,
but if you can just extract it from all
this Mumbo jumbo about one living
consciousness manifesting itself on the
material plane or in a rather more
potent and shorter three letter words
and I think that is very difficult to
introduce a narrative that will
supersede the narrative that you
articulated in no logo and subsequently
described the mutations in much of your
later work without a story that has I
more vital visceral,
deeper,
ancient,
potent human truth about one Sun God and
the nature of consciousness and the true
nature of interconnectivity and I think
that the response to sort of the this
was that knows anything.
The deer of capitalism has got to be a
similarly potent and motivating idea and
your point that the fact that apple and
Nike have to refer to in order to
motivate people to buy unnecessary and
in some cases brilliant trainers is is a
reference to oneness.
God's community profits with a Ph in
that for me is will.
We have to go back to that source.
The answer is not,
you know,
like for me like,
and I know next to nothing about
Marxism,
but it was the thing that sort of comes
up a lot in this podcast.
Perhaps it's good to,
I keep saying it,
but when mark talks about alienation,
when he's talking about the spiritual
problem of a mechanized and fully
industrialized culture that is not
controlled by its labor force,
that it's just that in itself is a
problem of the spirit and the,
my personal frustration around the
opponents of,
you know,
sort of like the,
the sort of,
the lighter side of the neoliberal
project is unwilling to not backtrack
but to embrace the spiritual side of
this because the new age stuff sounds to
me a bit sort of God,
not back crap,
but like,
you know,
but to recognize that there is room in
this discourse for what is this,
what it,
that we're fighting for?
Why is it,
why did it matter that we're human
beings?
Why does it matter that human beings in
the planet is in trouble?
Who Cares?
How do we avert avoid nihilism unless
it's with some deeper spiritual truth?
Well,
I mean,
I think there's a,
there's a little bit of a difference in
North America than here because of the
role of indigenous leadership in
progressive movements,
particularly in the climate movement and
in the environmental movement.
I mean,
every single major battleground against
a new mine,
against a nuclear waste dump against a
new pipeline is a fight that has
indigenous people at the forefront.
Um,
whether this is true in,
in Canada where I live,
it's true in the United States.
Uh,
it's true in Australia and New Zealand.
Um,
and,
and in most parts of the world,
um,
it's true in India.
That's true all over Latin America and
you know,
there are.
And so what's been interesting to me as
somebody who,
you know,
I,
I come more from the economic side of
the left,
Tino,
my early writing was all focused on
labor and human rights,
less,
less so the environment.
But for the past decade or so,
I've been very immersed in,
in the climate movement,
which I think is deeply interconnected
with all of those other issues.
And I find it really exciting to watch
the ways in which settler movements,
movements of,
of nonindigenous people are being
impacted by exposure to an indigenous
worldview that has the oneness that
you're describing at its center,
right?
Um,
you know,
if you're fighting a pipeline at
standing rock,
you are fighting that pipeline according
to the rules of the community there.
And they have the rules up,
uh,
you know,
on the side of the various structures in
the camp that say you are in ceremony.
This is not,
we are not protested.
We are protectors.
We're water protectors,
meaning we are protecting living systems
that protect all of life.
And when we march up to the police sign,
that is an act of ceremony that is not
an act of protest.
Right?
Um,
and it's,
um,
and,
and it creates,
you know,
one of the interesting conversations I
had at standing rock and every chapter,
but this in the book,
but I didn't describe this,
um,
conversation.
There was a,
a guy of a poet who I ran into there and
he'd been in many different left spaces,
protest spaces.
And he was just talking about how
different this was,
and one of things he said was really
different was that he said,
every movement that I've been a part of
has fetishized use and this,
this idea of just sort of perennially
starting over and just kind of hating
old people.
Whereas this is a culture that respects
wisdom,
hard won wisdom of elders,
not to say all older people are right,
but that there was,
it was a deeply intergenerational
movement that,
that young people were at the forefront,
but elders were,
were,
were teachers and leaders as well.
Um,
and it's just one of the ways that I
think the culture of the left is slowly
changing.
I think that's really important.
What you just said.
I don't have a hood that before I was
aware that the,
a pipeline,
a ceremony ceremony instead of protest
and immediately you,
her,
instead of protests,
protests,
that's really good because you're
denying the conventional lexicon,
which is what frames is.
You'll just protesting against this
natural progressive thing that's
supposed to be happening rather than
we'll protecting.
Yeah,
you're coming from a place of love.
You're coming from a place of love for
this land,
for these living systems that no one can
do without.
And um,
and,
and yes,
in order to do that,
you have to be against something.
You have to be against this pipeline
that is threatening the only source of
drinking water for this community.
But it's not driven.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a sort of a constant reminder that
it isn't hate that is dry.
It doesn't,
hatred of these oil companies are,
although,
although there's anger there and,
you know,
and there was opposition there,
um,
but the but it,
but it's serving this broader love.
And,
and,
and this is one of the things that,
you know,
people ask me stuff,
how do you,
how do you stay hopeful and all of this
in the movement.
And I think the reason why that question
comes up so much is because so many
people who are in spaces of opposition
or kind of pickled in anti,
you know,
in,
in that space for understandable
reasons,
right?
But in these,
her frontline environmental battles,
they really are so often about
communities falling more deeply in love
with the place,
you know,
with,
maybe it's their coast,
um,
you know,
understanding how dependent they are on
the streams and,
and,
and oceans that surround them.
And,
and learning about the interdependence
that was always there before,
but which we were ignored in our little
bubbles.
So the contingent of the culture that
has become prevalent that we live in the
from dislocation is a dominant idea that
you have no integral relationship to
your land.
You don't mind,
is distinct and superior to environment.
It is a resource for us to be used for
us to use,
uh,
the challenge of,
again,
if these ideas are stitched into ancient
cultures,
what else is there in there that we are
the gate in?
What else in there are we neglecting
wherever it's,
oh,
mindfulness is good for your heart or we
are one with our environment or the
shape,
uh,
the,
gay in marginalizing and humiliation of
the Shaman by the settler cultures.
When hunter gatherer of packs were
wrangled,
coiled and dis empowered.
So that cultures could be grounded so
that the earth could be subjugated and
our ability to live between realms,
to imagine new societies,
new ways of being like even by rejecting
the language,
drumming up,
drumming,
dancing,
these were all banned for indigenous
indigenous drumming.
Got Rid of all
their ceremony,
their music,
which yeah,
kill the culture.
And it's happened again and again.
And who did we do it to?
The British bright.
Basically everyone that we,
the ones doing it.
Actually Irish dumped by my.
That was,
I just got.
We were trying to artist.
What about those lovely trains we give
to the people of India?
They loved those trains come on.
And as a child,
what about culture?
Try and look at the tray about fish.
Newt.
Well,
if they're everywhere they'll be on the
train.
Stop Moaning.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's um,
I think this is important.
No,
me and I don't know quite how to make
such a potent idea.
Palatable to secularized people without
making it sound a bit crap and Hesi and
don't do what you're trying.
I really am trying to bring some of the
glory of God back into this,
a bit of fuel area,
bit of righteousness,
a bit of power,
a bit of archangel energy,
some flaming swords,
but like,
you know,
like nondenominational,
of course.
I mean I feel like every culture in the
world should find what connects them to
the land,
connects them to the one that's connects
them to one another.
And also I feel like I have to make it
bureaucratic and political for a moment.
Why the hell not that.
How is any sort of centralized system,
any post Westphalian clap trap about
nations ever going to work when people
can't be tied up in a Daf flag anymore.
It's too bigger idea served its
function.
Nationalisms broke globalization of the
type that we've had so far hasn't
Balderdash and has led to this
reemergence,
hasn't it?
Of um,
trumpkins Pumpkin as I like to call him.
Well,
I mean this is,
this is,
I mean we have to figure it out in a,
in a big hurry because we,
you know,
the climate clock has striking midnight.
We don't have a lot of time to,
to have a wakeup call.
It's interesting,
you know,
when I was writing my previous book,
this changes everything.
I mean,
my working title for that book was the
message,
um,
because told you not to do that.
The problem is when you,
when you search on the message,
you just get all this Bible stuff,
you know,
I mean it's just,
it's just really creepy.
Um,
but,
but the idea,
the message,
but the message was going to be here.
Homework was going to be messages that
climate change isn't an issue.
It's a message that is speaking to us in
the language of floods and fires and
storms and it's telling us to wake up
and it's telling us to evolve and it's
telling us that this system is broken.
Right?
And I think we are in this,
at this moment of overlapping system
failure.
Uh,
I think inequality is,
is an extraordinarily.
It just completely untenable levels.
I think thousands of people drowning in
the Mediterranean is also a message that
this is completely untenable.
I think grenfell tower is a message and
people are.
I think if there's some hope,
maybe it's that people are understanding
more and more these crises are messages
of system failure as soon as that fire
happened,
right?
I mean,
it was,
it was understood as being so far beyond
this one building,
but an expression of all of these failed
ideas,
right?
Um,
and this and this failed worldview and
the cruelty at the,
at the center of it.
Um,
so people are getting that in an instant
now.
Right?
So I think,
I think there,
I think that it is possible to have kind
of punctuated transformation,
these moments where suddenly things
start changing very quickly.
Um,
and you know,
if we look at moments where there has
been a radical progressive change,
it does tend to happen all at once.
Does it?
When did it?
Well,
um,
you know,
in,
after the,
in the midst of the Great Depression
after World War II,
after depression,
do suppression,
new deal,
social security,
um,
after the second world war,
public health care and yet,
um,
and,
and then the environmental law laws,
the legal infrastructure protecting
endangered species.
I mean this,
this happened one like,
like just a flurry of laws,
the things with big responses to like
everyone's fogged out,
you know what I mean?
Lots of luck.
I don't know much about what happened in
the Great Depression,
but then you think there was a huge
number of people like,
oh,
we better start now because there's too
many of them on my off the Second World
War.
Oh,
we've just killed millions of people.
We better do something.
So it's like these things are like isn't
in a way while suicide,
numerous positive benefits,
just a way of power maintain in itself
like centralized power going,
well this is the bare minimum we can do
the bare minimum we can do.
There's just got a bit higher for a
moment they're going to need to help
service.
But after that we can probably carry on
doing what we're doing,
isn't it?
What we actually need is a massive
deconstruction of power.
Like isn't it like anything that.
Wouldn't it be good to have some big
jazzy global campaigns?
I'm a very visually effective and
potent.
Like we are going to destroy apple logo,
that kind of thing.
Like we're going to take one big
corporation and we organize a global
movement,
destroy.
It probably sounds a bit less popular
and brilliant products got off that
phone or gm or something where you can
say like that thing
that's digital,
you know,
so fruit globalize,
attacking of the brand,
protesting,
like just to demonstrate,
but at the same way like to demonstrate
the potency of mobilization,
to take one,
one victory to one symbol,
one thing go right.
Why don't we attack that thing?
That was the plot of the TV show.
What was that hacker show?
Russell branch.
Was it what Mr.
Mr.
Robot.
Mr Roberts said what happened?
Did it go well for Mr.
Robot was the second series of Mr.
Robot,
get back to me.
Tell me if the revolutionary idea of
bringing down one massive bluechip
corporation works.
Not Easy.
A good idea,
Naomi.
I mean I was interested in your
conversation with geodes about just,
you know,
where is the power and the being in
these rooms filled with supposedly
powerful people in the power isn't
there,
you know?
And,
and yeah,
I think if,
if people could see a deconstruction of
one of these symbols of what he calls
the deep state,
it,
it could be quite empowering.
But I also think it can,
I think this spell of powerlessness,
I mean this,
this extreme era of corporate power
that,
that in most parts of the world is
called Neo liberalism.
I mean,
that really is dying.
And,
and,
or is it mutating,
do you think?
How do,
what do you,
what evidence is there a bit dying?
Uh,
it's,
it's a Zombie ideology because as it
advanced,
this was it.
This was a project of ideas that had
true believers that would sit down and
earnestly tell you that if we
privatized,
you know,
the,
the rails for energy and water,
good things will happen,
right?
They will work better,
they will be cheaper.
I mean,
there aren't,
there's nobody left to defend
deregulation,
privatization,
low taxes and cuts to social spending.
It's,
it's stumbling around.
And I think you accurately described as
kind of a Zombie ideology,
right?
Because it has its own momentum.
But this is why we're in this very
dangerous moment because there is a
vacuum of ideas and these very
dangerous,
right wing white supremacist type or
misogynist ideas are surging represented
by the donald trumps of the world.
And the meeting the pens,
there's enough of them.
Or is it because we live in bubbles all
day?
All I'd ever meet him.
I never made people who actually
sincerely go.
Now he's a that Donald Trump.
I never meet them or they just say,
don't say out loud.
What's going on?
Well,
they're,
they're out there.
They're out there in the voting.
Well,
I mean,
I think the forces that he's tapping
into never went away.
He didn't create it,
right?
Um,
but,
but this vacuum is potent.
It's dangerous,
but it also is filled with
possibilities.
And um,
and so,
and I feel like it's this very slow
decomposition,
this slow and the part of the neoliberal
project that is slowest to die is not
the policies we can.
I mean,
look,
I was on the BBC this morning.
We were talking about the fact that the
Tory government here is talking about
abolishing tuition fees.
I mean,
there's nobody left to defend austerity,
but the.
I think the,
it turns out that the piece of it that
was sturdiest was there is no
alternative,
right?
More on the imagination is what
outlasted the policies themselves and
that's what starting to lift because you
have this whole generation of young
people who didn't get the indoctrination
that you got and that I got because
their whole adult life is post 2008
financial crisis when all the true
believers fled for the hills.
They are still trying to oppose brutal
imposed brutal austerity on Greece and
Spain.
But there's nobody out there saying this
is going to be good and don't you dare
think anything else.
Right?
So they're free.
They're much freer than we were.
They never got the hard sell on
resentment and I think I'll give him a
bit of an indoctrinating myself.
No,
I mean,
what do you mean by the inner trump?
What do you mean by the trump within?
Well,
I mean this comes back to,
you know,
this idea of treating trump as totally
other.
And when I,
when I first started working on this
book,
I just happened,
I was at a literary festival and they
seated me next to a real Hillary Clinton
Democrat.
Um,
and,
and I explained the book I was working
on and you know,
trump as sort of the,
the logical conclusion of all of these
trends.
And she was sort of nodding along and
then I,
you know,
I said,
this is,
these are American trans.
And she was like,
no,
it's not like we're Obama,
you know,
and she wanted to just completely
disavow trump,
you know,
that he was,
it was only red states.
It was only the,
right.
It had nothing to do with the broader,
the,
sorry,
the broader culture.
Um,
so I just don't buy it.
I mean,
I just see him as just this
manifestation of everything that is
going wrong in our culture.
Just this for our fractured attention
span.
The fact that he doesn't read just the
word,
give it to me in a list.
You know,
Alyssa is what he's,
he's,
he's a good.
Is growing punishment.
Make another list.
That'll be a good experiment.
Well,
uh,
don't do things that run shorter list 30
things that room
that is fascinating,
but he is symptomatic or not that
because how could it be otherwise?
I mean like what people's unwillingness
through revise the Obama presidency
because not now obviously comparatively,
superficially,
personally,
he seems like some sort of gorgeous
Christ.
But actually what he was doing was
laying the foundations for what happened
subsequently because you can't ask trump
if what happened before it was nice.
Oh,
and you know,
I think with the,
part of the,
part of my argument that is,
is most uncomfortable for American
liberals is,
is the argument that I don't think we
could have trump without Bill Clinton
and bill gates because the,
those two men more than any others
fostered this idea that billionaires are
gonna save us,
right?
We don't have billionaires are countries
doing it.
Richard Branson,
he was going to fix climate change right
in his spare time.
And um,
and Bill Gates is going to fix malaria
and we don't need,
you know,
he had bill gates now has more power
than the World Health Organization.
No,
me,
I went to this island,
Richard Branson's island,
right.
You owned it.
It was in the British Virgin Islands.
It was a tax haven and on it there was a
symposium being held that was about how
are we going to make the world a better
place and one of the things I said so
while on the island and which expediated
by hasty departure by teddy atlas,
lower like one.
This is a tax haven in it.
Why don't we just live like operate
within the.
Even the existing systems will be
slightly better than this one and my
friend actually said like during the
eighties when everything was whoosh
crash,
Bang,
Wallop,
Richard Branson was bombing about not
air balloons and speed boats and
everyone's shitting themselves.
He's like,
I don't know,
perhaps we should legalize drugs and you
know,
have a sort of a bit more concerned for
the environment,
which is again an attempt to rebrand,
cooperate and appropriate the conscious
energies of an awakening people,
but of course trump is intimately
connected to a Bama,
to Bill Gates to Bill Clinton because it
is one interconnected system that's
feeding off itself.
Now the other risk we have is getting
like,
you know,
wandering into what our call with love
and affection,
the ICC paddock,
where David Eick,
we're like,
like were sort of like if you've talked
to much about sort of interconnected
global systems that feed each other,
hold each other together,
have operated for a long time.
People's,
let's go,
hang on a second.
This is a big crack pot.
So I'm very much value research based,
empirical,
secular sounding data because I think
it's vital to be taken seriously,
but somehow there has to be a marriage
between this sort of,
this academic data based researched
proper academic staff and the power of
interconnection with people,
the ability to stir viscerally human
beings,
to make them die,
live,
love,
sacrifice,
which they're not going to do for
academia.
I think you,
I think you're right.
And,
and I,
we live in a beautiful moment where
these words worlds are converging.
Uh,
and you know,
I think that what we're learning from
science is intensely beautiful and
spiritual.
We talk about it as if it's something
dry and remote.
Um,
but this is the study of life.
Yes,
but because I suppose that that in
itself got colonized.
The idea of scientific,
uh,
endeavor became mechanized.
The way that's the most research is
funded is like,
if you look at the,
where the funding comes from,
who's,
who does the grail serve,
who does the grail serve Naomi.
Now my producer,
he's not my producer.
He's a free independent human being who
happens to be producing this show is
holding up a bit of paper that says No.
Basically whiteboard says change.
Or I come a normally we can do this
together.
Resistance,
black lives matter,
recapturing the imagination.
And if he's not,
imagination isn't recaptured by my
religious ranting.
I thought that was wrong with him and
Naomi's leap manifesto that's covered
these topics before you go off to your
next appointment,
probably the mainstream media little
snip your words of wisdom into some
actually meeting with some black lives
matter activists about Grenville Tower.
Oh yeah.
This is my cell out appointment of the
day.
This and that.
It's not true with an entered Martin
this morning.
There you go right there.
So it's in a way you're creating
steadily more authentic,
you know,
you to talk to other black lives matter,
you're gonna have to commune with pure
consciousness.
No,
I,
I think what that is a reference to as a
section in the book about the fact that
social movements really are recovering
the utopian imagination,
really dreaming and public,
not just being an opposition.
And one of them most inspiring examples
of this is the movement for black lives
and in the,
in the United States,
which came up with this policy platform
called the vision for black lives,
which is,
it's a,
it's a political platform without a
political party.
It's,
it came out about through a very
participatory grassroots process.
It is the,
it is a response not only to police
violence though though it is that it
covers everything from abolishing
prisons,
the war on drugs,
restructuring the tax system,
reparations for slavery.
And it's very,
very bold.
And this is what we haven't seen from
progressive movements is coming together
and saying,
well,
what,
what does the world look like after we
win a vision?
Um,
and this is why I say the last piece of
the neoliberal project to die is this
war on the imagination and the,
the leap manifesto is it is a project
that I've been involved in in Canada,
which was an attempt to do this a couple
of years ago.
We helped host a meeting of 60 movement
organizers from a broad cross section of
movements,
indigenous rights,
food justice,
climate,
labor,
uh,
some,
some faith organizations coming together
and just trying to agree on the yes.
And,
and,
and what was so interesting about that
at meeting was just how hard it was to
be honest.
You know,
that that muscle,
we didn't have a muscle memory of
agreeing on what we want.
We had a memory of coming together to
oppose things.
We'd come together to say we don't want
this free trade deal.
We hate this politician.
We don't want this austerity bill.
Um,
but we did not have experience of like,
well,
what does it look like when we win?
What is,
what do we,
what do we agree on about what the world
should look like in the future?
And one of the things that we had to do
was not rely on some easy nostalgia of
just like this idea that everything was
great in the 19 seventies because the
indigenous people in the room and the
people representing immigrant
organizations in the room,
we're just having none of that.
Like we're not romanticizing the
seventies.
So we're going to have to gain our left
movements have done that for far too
long.
Right?
So we're going to have to be inspired by
a world we haven't seen yet.
We haven't created yet.
Um,
so yeah,
if people are interested they can go to
the leap.org.
I'm interested and I'm a people and I
include the whole manifesto at the,
at the end of the book too.
It's not long,
it's 1400 words.
If people are rewriting it,
that some people are using it to run
slates of candidates to take over.
City Council will use that.
And it's just,
you're not waiting for a politician to
come along and figure all this out
because I think we are in a moment where
people are maybe a little vulnerable to
save yours.
And a lot of trouble because,
let me tell you this,
but by the way,
my joke about your Messiah tour is not
finished.
It's a long shot.
It's people like you who I worry about.
I don't know.
That's a bit of archive that's going to
get pulled up in 20 years.
Here's Naomi Klein is fueled in a brand
archive is a.
don't call me that in public.
No,
sorry.
So okay.
I think the main things I've learned
from this conversation and really,
really enjoyed was allowed to miss him.
I lot the idea that we got the twitching
Zombie corpse of capitalism lunging
about now lashing about all baffled and
confused and bereft of ideas that
there's a necessity for New Vision.
And I think that we got from Naomi
client and what you were saying about
like some of those protests we have
indigenous people is a reimagining of
interconnectivity and oneness,
which previously has been regarded.
The terrain of what I noticed you call
faith organizations.
I think more of them kind of summarize
where people diverse people to come up
with an opposing on subsequent vision.
He's a real powerful.
I like that and we're going to look at
leap dot Org and learn more to see if
people can run that.
Watch out for.
Don't follow leaders.
Watch your pocket.
Me Watch out for Messiah Masonic figures
that some of the other things we've
learned as well.
Is it?
Yep.
I'd have free people like don't point
is rude to point and say you enjoyed
that big bucket of customers.
Just stop complaining.
Naomi about Britain.
We've opened our doors to you.
We've shared.
Knew nothing but love.
That's Naomi Klein there.
Thank you for being such a wonderful
guest as always.
Thank you.
So that was fun.
That show was sponsored by me and my
rebirth to the next couple of shows.
As I've said,
it's sold out,
but if you want to go and see me and
grim.
Oh,
on the 10th of July or Richmond in the
17th of July layer.
Cambridge.
I ain't for July 25th of July.
Can Go Russell brand.com.
Get tickets.
If you liked this show,
subscribe and review it.
If you tell him just um,
well listen to this one.
In the end.
I mean,
you must like it.
Stop torturing yourself.
Okay.